والله تبين الصراحه من اجمل اجمل الهاكات
اللي سويتها انا اسافر يعني كثير سويت
كثير من الهاكات هذه واحده من
[موسيقى]
اجمل عاده ننا نطلع هيك ولا نسمع هيك يكون
اللي هو من سطح الارض للقمه صح بس هذا
الهايك ميزه اللي هو وه يكون من من قمه
لقمه يعني انت تبدين الهايك القمه تطلعين
من قمه بيكو يوريو
لبيكو روفو فهذا المميز كان
في التحديات وصعوبه المسار ان مش سيده
طالع ونازل والغلطه اللي سويتها انا ما
اخط معي اكل صار عندي مثل هبوط الحمد لله
بس يوم وصلت القمه الثانيه كان في مطعم
وكلت والحمد لله ورجعت بعدين مسام ثاني 5
كيلو
[موسيقى]
ونص لازم تكونين لابسه اللبس اللائق للهيك
اللي هو الشوز اهم شي الشوز والجاكيت لانه
يكون في برد فوق ونفس الوقت يستوي حر اذا
الشمس طلعت تستو حر واذا الشمس راحتو برد
فيكون اللبس الكامل مع سواء كان البرد ولا
[موسيقى]
s